les réactions à CH des ministres et des
parlementaires en direct de la sortie de
l'hémicycle retrouveznous tous les jours
en direct pour suivre les temps fort des
textes en Séan et des
auditions dans preuve par 3 je mets à
l'épreuve les responsables politiques
sans concession autour de 3
temps grand politique du soir qui
décrypte l'actualité du
jour le club des municipales c'est le
rendez-vous électoral de l'année sur la
chaîne Public Sénat où j'inviterai
autour de moi l'ensemble de mes
confrères pour débattre et décryter des
grands enjeux locaux de cette élection
déshabillonsles c'est l'émission où je
déshabille les politiques en tout bien
tout
honneur en cette année d'élection
municipale itinéraris reprend la route à
la découverte de ville en pleine
transformation pour une balade dans une
France
inattendue Europe et c'est l'actualité
européenne dans tous ces
états dans Génération Europe on parle
des enjeux de l'Europe avec des
étudiants français et
étrangers l'actualité politique vue du
web bibliothèque une émission
littéraireonnue de référ pour les
auteurs leurs livres et pour le public
dans un lieu
exceptionnel culture t c'est l'émission
de tous les arts dans tous les
territoires un lie une histoire je suis
heureux de vous retrouver pour de
nouvelles conversations sur les haut
lieux de la Grande
Guerre les pieds sur terre c'est le
rendez-vous des initiatives
écol enquête d'Europe c'est une manière
singulière de montrer et raconter
l'Europe le docu débat c'est un
documentaire suivi d'un débat pour
prolonger la
discussion
ce pourrait être un comportement correct
monsieur le
Président merci Monsieur ponatovski donc
aé donné de votre rappel au règlement
moi j'applique la décision de la
Conférence des Présidents monsieur le
président de la commission des lois a
demandé la
parole monsieur monsieur le le président
monsieur le ministre je vous remercie de
me donner la parole à la suite de
l'intervention de Monsieur poniatovski
je comprends tout à fait le le sentiment
qui peut être le sien mais je dois dire
que nous avons l'occasion de nous
trouver les uns et les autres dans la
même situation puisque l'ordre du jour
des temps réservés au groupe est fixé
librement par chacun des groupes donc il
y a un groupe ici qui a fixé les 4
heures en en inscrivant de textes dans
l'ordre qu'il a souhaité et ensuite vous
savez très bien bien que les l'ordre de
parole entre les différents groupes est
fixé en vertu d'une règle qui s'applique
à tout le monde qui est une règle dite
de
tourniqué qui fait qu'elle
est
donc votre groupe parlera nécessairement
lors ce que ce texte reviendra bien
entendu au titre d'un nouveau temps
réservé comme il sera loisible au groupe
concerné de
l'inscrire en fonction de sa liberté
puisque la Conférence des Présidents
respecte très strictement ce que
demandent les groupes pour le temps
réservé donc il y a peut-être une
réflexion qui peut-être menée là-dessus
d'ailleurs monsieur le président
Jean-Pierre belle a décidé de réunir
prochainement les membres du bureau et
de la Conférence des Présidents et il a
d'ailleurs demandé que des propositions
puissent être faites ce pourrait être
une proposition pourrait placer le
tourniquet par un système dans lequel il
y aurait simultanément la parole à
l'opposition au groupes minoritaires et
majoritair mais les règles étant ce
qu'elle est elle est strictement
appliqué nous en subissons tous les
avantages et les
inconvénients merci monsieur le
Président de
mesard monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues vient de VI
de m'indiquer quelles étaient les
observations de notre collègue
poniatovski je les comprends
parfaitement je vis d'abord le rassurer
sur les intentions en tout cas de notre
groupe je ne pense pas qu'il y
ait beaucoup de de différences sur nos
convictions en ce qui concerne
l'énergie par contre par rapport au
passage nous sommes tout à fait disposé
à
renoncer à notre passage en numéro 3 sur
le groupe pour lui permettre de
s'exprimer à notre place car il serait
vraiment de très mauvais goût
effectivement que le débat soit tronqué
mais pour ce qui me concerne je ne peux
pas faire autre chose nous n'aurons ni
le ministre et je me suis exprimé
là-dessus tout à l'heure il serait bon
que ce débat qui est important sur
lequel il y a beaucoup de choses à dire
d'autant qu'il y a eu des annonces ce
matin encore sur l'avenir de la filière
nucléaire ça tombait bien de nous dire
ce matin que SIM serait fermé en 2016
donc ça justifiait encore plus un vrai
débat merci monsieur le Président mesard
Monsieur le Ministre
oui deux deux observations la première
pour excuser Philippe Martin quand le
président mard a suggéré demandé plus
exactement l'inscription de ce débat
j'ai immédiatement dit qu'il y aurait un
problème puisque l'Assemblée nationale
débat ce matin deux propositions de loi
dans le domaine qui est de celui de la
compétence du ministre de
l'Environnement et donc j'avais averti
que dans ces conditions-là il ne
pourrait pas être présent que c'est
notre ministre donc le ministre des
Relations avec le Parlement et qui
serait présent deuxièmement sur
l'organisation le gouvernement n'y peut
ni'y peut met puisque c'est le résultat
d'une organisation interne au Sénat sur
lequel je n'ai pas d'appréciation
apporter troisièmement je n'ai pas le
droit d'intervenir concernant ce débat
au moment ou je le souhaiterais mais
uniquement à la fin et donc il y a me
semble-t-il une réalité c'est que le
gouvernement ne pourra pas parler contte
tenu de l'horaire je le regrette mais
naturellement même si j'avais eu ce
droit l'important c'est que d'abord les
parlementaires s'expriment et le
gouvernement même s'il l'avait eu ne
l'aurait pas
utilisé merci Monsieur le Ministre on va
arrêter là parce que sinon personne va
pouvoir s'exprimer je vais donner la
parole à Monsieur Stéphan Mazard pour le
groupe RDSE auteur de la
proposition de ce
matin monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le groupe
RDSE auquel j'appartiens est très
attentif aux questions d'énergie il a
suivi l'année dernière avec vigilance le
débat sur la transition énergétique il
s'intéresse aujourd'hui activement au
travail de préparation du projet de loi
sur la transition énergétique il veille
à susciter dès qu'il peut un large débat
sur ces questions notamment dans cette
enceinte c'est d'ailleurs la troisème
fois que nous débattons d'énergie en
séance publi et ce à notre initiative en
moins d'un an au Sénat il est en effet
selon nous de la responsabilité du
Parlement et des politiques de s'emparer
de cette question et de prendre les
décisions structurante indispensable
pour l'avenir de notre pays pour son
indépendance pour la compétitivité de
nos entreprises et le bien-être de nos
concitoyens il ne peut être question de
laisser les décisions aux experts
techniciens ou autres technocrates
particulièrement nombreux dans ce
domaine même si leur compétence n'est
pas en cause loin de là il nous revient
aussi de maîtriser le calendrier et de
déterminer le rythme des évolutions
nécessaires car il nous faut faire face
à l'importance des enjeux et répondre à
la prise de conscience par nos
concitoyens de la rareté des matières
premières non renouvelables notamment
les énergies fossiles cette rareté est
devenue une réalité elle est en partie
la cause du montant élevé de notre
facture énergétique qui atteint environ
70 milliards d'euros aujourd'hui soit
pratiquement le montant de notre déficit
extérieur et les 3/4 de cette facture
sont du aux
hydrocarbures les conséquences de cette
dépendance aux énergies fossiles qui a
un impact pratiquement irréversible sur
le réchauffement climatique sont
également bien connus le dernier rapport
du JC le fameux groupe d'experts
intergouvernemental sur l'évolution du
climat Paris au mois de septembre
fournit des analyses nombreuses et
approfondies à ce sujet les travaux de
l'Onerc l'observatoire national sur les
effets du réchauffement climatique
organisme créés je le rappelle à
l'initiative de notre haute assemblée
sont aussi très éclairants les récentes
intempéries connues en France en Europe
et ailleurs témoigent aussi cruellement
de ces dérèglements
climatiques la recherche et le
développement de solutions alternatives
à nos modèles de croissance économique
et surtout à nos manières d'utiliser les
ressources énergétiques sont donc plus
que jamais prioritaire nous devons
tendre vers une économie de plus en plus
décarboné pour réduire les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre et réduire
l'augmentation de la température à la
surface de notre globe nous le savons le
monde globalisé dans lequel nous vivons
aujourd'hui doit évoluer et trouver
collectivement les meilleures façons de
permettre à tous les habitants de la
planète de vivre mieux sans épuiser à
tout jamais le patrimoine naturel dont
il dispose en particulier en matière
énergétique dans ce contexte
l'indépendance énergétique de la France
est un objectif incontournable qui
repose sur deux piliers qui sont aussi
deux filières d'excellence le nucléaire
et les énergies renouvelables s ajoute
en contrepoint la nécessité d'une plus
grande efficacité énergétique dans les
trois cas ce sont des emplois et des
technologies de l'activité et de
l'innovation des leviers pour le
développement économique y compris local
ces filières stratégiques sont en effet
des secteurs véritablement porteurs pour
l'avenir de nos territoires de nos
concitoyens et de notre pays le Sénat
doit en être pleinement conscient et
jouer un rôle déterminant dans les choix
qui vont être faits et nous engager pour
les prochaines
années le chantier de la transition
énergétique est donc crucial il doit
aboutir à un mix énergétique crédible et
adapté aux ressources de notre pays
incluant bien entendu l'électricité
nucléaire mais aussi l'utilisation de la
géothermie de la biomasse des courants
marins du vent du soleil certes il y a
encore beaucoup d'incertitude sur les
défis auxquels nous devrons faire faire
face à quel rythme vont s'épuiser les
ressources fossiles comment va évoluer
notre consommation électrique quels sont
les gains de productivité que l'on peut
raisonnablement attendre des différentes
filières des énergies renouvelables ce
qui est toutefois certain c'est que nous
ne devons pas nous priver de l'avantage
compétitif incontestable que représente
notre filière nucléaire bien sûr il faut
adapter nos centrales et prendre et
prendre en compte le coût des
investissements de sûreté du
démantellement du traitement des déchets
de la recherche mais nous nous vons pas
pénaliser inutilement nos entreprises et
nos concitoyens car nous devons aussi
être au rendez-vous des objectifs que
nous nous sommes fixés pour réduire nos
émissions à gaz à effet de serre et qui
nous engage sur le plan
européen nous avons jusqu'ici respecté
les grandes lignes du paquet énergie-
climat comme l'a souligné la Cour des
comptes dans un rapport rendu publicique
la semaine dernière mais ce sera de plus
en plus difficicile dans les années qui
viennent ce paquet repose sur trois
objectifs pour 2020 20 % de réduction
des gaz à effet de serre 20 % d'énergie
renouvelable 20 % de gain d'efficacité
énergétique la Commission européenne a
même annoncé hier qu'elle souhaitait
aller encore plus loin avec une
réduction de 40 % des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre à l'horizon 2030 et au
moins 25 % 27 % d'énergie renouvelable
dans la consommation finale d'énergie or
comme le dit la Cour des comptes si la
part des énergies renouvelables est
passée de 9,6 % en 2005 à 13,1 % en 2012
les 20 % seront difficiles à atteindre à
l'horizon 2020 pour les atteindre elle
évalue que l'accroissement de la
production d'électricité renouvelable
devait être six fois plus important dans
les 6 années qui viennent que sur la
période
2005-211 et SEP fois plus important
encore pour la chaleur
renouvelable cela suppose des
investissements substantiels et la Cour
des comptes souigne en particulier la
nécessité de de renforcer les réseaux
pour acccorder ces nouvelles sources
d'énergie les coûts estimés par RTE et
ERDF pour le renforcement des réseaux
s'élève au total à 5,5 milliards d'euros
la Cour des comptes préconise aussi de
revoir les méthodes de soutien et de
financement de la politique de
développement des énergies renouvelables
comme elle avait déjà fait dans son
rapport de juillet
2013 dans ce rapport la Cour
recommandait que soi réalisés des
arbitrages entre les filières pour pr ég
les plus
efficientes soit l'éolien soit la
chaleur renouvelable plus que le
photovoltaïque ou l'électricité
géothermique pour ces deux dernières
filières en effet la Cour estime qu'une
partie substantielle des moyens
importants consacrés au soutien à la
production devrait
plutôtêre être pardon réorienté vers la
recherche le débat actuel sur le projet
de loi de transition énergétique doit
porter cette ambition et se donner comme
obligation de mettre en place les
conditions d'une véritable révolution
énergétique dans notre pays il nous faut
filière par filière tout mettre en œuvre
pour soutenir nos entreprises et
relocaliser les emplois perdus au cours
des dernières années car oui tous les
secteurs des énergies renouvelables ont
souffert de manque de soutien au cours
des dernières années et sont en attente
de mesures fortes de la part du
gouvernement plusieurs annonces
appellent à projet ou à manifestation
d'intérêt assouplissement législatifs ou
règlementaires sont néanmoins allés dans
ce sens au cours des derniers mois et
nous nous en réjouissons mais il reste
encore un cap stratégique et des
objectifs ambitieux à déterminer c'est
le cas pour l'éolien la petite
hydroélectricité les énergies marines la
biomasse mais aussi pour le
photovoltaïque ou la
géothermie dans les futures décisions il
faudra veiller à ne plus commettre les
mêmes erreurs que par le passé je pense
notamment au photovoltaïqu la politique
menée a malheureusement été un échec
pour nos entreprises et nos emplois nous
avons ouvert en grand les portes de
notre notre pays au panneaux
photovoltaïque étranger et ceux qui
veulent encore croire à cette énergie à
laquelle nombre de rapports promettent
pourtant un bel avenir doivent se
débattre avec une politique tarifaire
inconséquente et des procédures d'appel
d'offre qui n'aboutissent pas le
gouvernement a récemment annoncé des
mesures de relance de la filière mais
j'attire votre attention sur le fait
qu'il y a une véritable urgence on ne
peut plus continuer à laisser sans
réponse les acteurs de ce secteur qui
participent aux appels d'offre avec des
projets économiques
viable face à ces défis nous pensons
qu'au-delà des arbitrages
gouvernementaux les collectivités
territoriales ont un rôle à jouer elles
peuvent être les catalyseurs du
développement de la part des énergies
renouvelables dans notre système
énergétique notamment pour la production
d'électricité il convient donc qu'ell
puisse exercer cette compétence d'une
manière optimale car elles sont les
mieux placéses pour favoriser la mise en
œuvre de solutions à la fois adapté
adapté aux besoins et intégré par
exemple en joignant la question du
traitement des déchets à celle de la
production de réseaux de chaleur ou
d'électricité comme l'ont bien montré
les travaux menés dans le cadre du débat
national le processus de la transition
énergétique suppose des changements très
importants dans les comportements et les
technologies et la question posée est
bien celle de comment enclencher ces
changements nous savons que les outils
existent les normes la tarification la
fiscalité mais il faut une volonté pour
les mettre en œuvre et le souci de les
prévoir dans la durée les normes par
exemple peuvent avoir un impact fort
dans le domaine du bâtiment de
l'automobile ou de l'industrie mais ce
n'est pas tout de le dire encore faut-il
agir et à bonant de ce point de vue si
tout le monde convient du fait que la
rénovation thermique des bâtiments est
l'une des sources les plus prometteuses
d'économie d'énergie et plus encore
d'emploi on ne peut que constater aussi
le retard pris dans les décisions sur
les décrets et arrêtés d'application sur
la formation et cetera ce retard n'est
pas admissible tant il y a urgence tant
les retombées sont importantes pour nos
entreprises pour l'emploi pour la vie
quotidienne de nos concitoyens et bien
sûr aussi pour notre bilan
énergétique deux autres outils doivent
être utilisés avec discernement celui de
la tarification d'abord ce n'est pas un
outil simple à manier mais adapté aux
enjeu la tarification doit permettre de
faire évoluer les comportements et
promouvoir une autre composition du mix
énergétique l'expérience allemande de
tarification des énergies renouvelables
doit d'ailleurs être un élément de
réflexion dans ce débat autre moyen la
fiscalité elle peut-être efficace et
même très efficace dès lors toutefois
qu'elle est accompagnée pour éviter
certains de ces effets pervers c'est un
domaine où les marges sont assez grandes
mais délicates à mettre en œuvre je
pense à la fiscalité sur le gazol les
agrocarburant mais aussi au dispositifs
de soutien aux nouvelles filières comme
le photovoltaïque domaine dans lequel
nous avons malheureusement eu une
politique bien trop ératique et
insuffisamment réfléchie le processus de
la transition énergétique suppose donc
de favoriser les énergies les plus
compétitives mais aussi celles qui vont
permettre de remplir les objectifs fixés
à l'échelon européens cela signifie en
particulier qu'il faut enclencher avec
plus de volontarisme le développement
des boucles énergétiques locales que ce
soit pour l'électricité la chaleur ou
encore le gaz monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues le chantier de la
transition énergétique est crucial il
doit aboutir à un mix énergétique
crédible et adapté aux ressources de
notre pays il doit permettre à tous les
acteurs concernés des participés ce qui
nous met dans l'obligation de créer les
conditions les plus favorables à
l'objectif d'indépendance énergétique
indispensable pour l'avenir de nos
territoires et de nos concitoyens le
débat national sur la transition
énergétique qui s'est achevée a permis
une très forte mobilisation de
l'ensemble des acteurs économiques
syndicaux politiques associatifs de
notre pays sur un sujet d'importanceces
majeure pour les 30 prochaines années il
a eu le grand mérite de faire apparaître
un fort consensus sur la la volonté de
faire que la France soit un acteur
déterminant en matière d'innovation
énergétique la préparation de la
conférence mondiale sur le climat de
2015 qui se tiendra à Paris nous impose
également de viser l'exemplarité dans ce
processus de la transition
énergétique merci Monsieur Stéphane
Mazar dans la suite du débat la parole
est à Madame
kckerman
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues tout
d'abord permettez-moi d'excuser ma
collègue mille Church qui a dû partir
avant la fin de de ce
débat puisque cette c'est un vaste sujet
donct le Sénat est saisi ce matin et
nousous efforcerons en 7 minutes d'y
apporter notre contribution en plaçant
la question de la production énergétique
au cœur de la transition énergétique et
en gardant à l'esprit sa dimension
européenne et internationale du secteur
vous nous pardonnerez dès lors de ne pas
nous focaliser sur la seule production
nationaleélectricité afin d'éviter de
tomber dans une opposition stérile entre
énergie renouvelable et nucléaire au
contraire les enjeux pour nos citoyens
se situe au-delà dans le choix ou non
d'une maîtrise publique de la politique
énergétique d'une association des
salariés et des usagers afin de garantir
le droit à l'énergie pour tous et
l'acceptabilité des choix qui sont faits
il n'est pas inutile que chacun clarifie
sa position sur ces points en 2011 les
sénateurs de gauche avait voté pour une
proposition de résolution de notre
groupe dans laquelle il était écrit je
cite le Sénat affirme que les activités
de production de transport de
distribution et de commercialisation
doivent être entièrement publiques et
placés sous le contrôle de la puissance
publique dans le cadre d'un pôle public
de l'énergie qui associe les citoyens et
les travailleurs du secteur énergétique
3 ans plus tard les prises de position
semblent oublié et le gouvernement n'a
pas jugé utile de revenir sur les lois
de libéralisation et de privatisation du
secteur énergétique porté par la droite
ensuite aborder la question de la
politique énergétique au travers des
filières industrielles de production
c'est également parler des réseaux de
distribution et de transport énergétique
à ce sujet il serait illusoire de penser
que la transition énergétique se se fera
par une production délocalisée de
l'énergie dans laquelle chaque
territoire pourrait produire pour ses
besoins locaux son énergie les contrats
techniqu en terme de sécurité et
d'indépendance énergétique s'y opposent
enfin pour se prononcer sur les filières
de production il faut également
organiser les moyens d'une moindre
consommation énergétique des efforts
doivent être consentis dans la
rénovation des logements mais ils ne
doivent pas peser sur les ménages qui
n'ont d'autre choix que de vivre dans
des logements et énergivore de plus il
est important d'inclure le secteur des
transports des personnes et de de
marchandises dans le débat y compris
pour faire un bilan carbone des énergies
renouvelables en France les transports
constituent le premier secteur
d'activité responsable de la
consommation d'énergie et d'émission de
gaz à effet de serre la mondialisation
de l'économie est un facteur clé de
l'explosion des émission de gaz à effet
de serre au-delà de la question de
l'avenir des différentes filières que
j'aborderai dans quelques instant an il
nous semblait essentiel donc de rappeler
que l'énergie n'est pas une marchandise
et que la politique énergétique doit
faire partie d'une réflexion plus
globale sur la politique économique et
les limites évidentes du modèle de la
concurrence libre et non faussée dans
une économie
mondialisé alors que les prévisions du
GC sur le réchauffement climatique nous
commandent de réduire de 50 % les
émissions planétaires de CO2 d'ici 2050
et même de 80 % dans les pays
industrialisés les plus développés nous
sommes très loin même en Europe de nous
diriger vers la tenue de ces objectifs
cet impératif absolu semble avoir
disparu d'ailleurs du débat public
l'expérience allemande avec une
production énergétique ici du issue du
charbon en augmentation doit nous
conduire à réfléchir sur les
alternatives du au nucléaire le
réchauffement climatique menace l'avenir
de nos sociétés humaines et implique un
recul massif de l'utilisation des
énergies fossiles la production
énergétique en France doit donc
s'articuler autour d'un objectif de
diversification complémentaire des
sources d'énergie le développement des
énergies renouvelables comme relais des
énergies utilisant les ressources
fossile ne saurait à ce jour exclure le
recours à un nucléaire mieux sécurisé
dans un mix énergétique rééquilibré le
recul des énergies é maîtrises de CO2
entraînera forcément une augmentation
notable de la part de la production
d'électricité décarboné dans le bilan
énergétique global les productions dans
le bilan énergétique global les
productions pardon énergétique qu'ell
soit thermique électrique ou chimique ne
répondent pas aux mêmes usages et ne
sont pas interchangeables l'électricité
a part exemple une grande souplesse
d'utilisation cependant nous ne savons
pas la stocker et c'est là un enjeu
d'avenir il est nécessaire de renforcer
les recherches dans les batteries le
pompage returbinage ou l'utilisation de
l'hydrogène à ce titre nous serons très
attentifs aux proposition annoncée du
gouvernement pour le développement de
cette filière
d'hydrogène la production hydraulique
stockable et très souple peut sans doute
encore progresser mais chacun comprend
que les sites disponibles sont limités
cette source d'énergie est un atout
majeur de la France et nous réaffirmons
ici au gouvernement notre condamnation
la plus ferme de l'ouverture à la
concurrence des concessions hydrauliques
ce serait une erreur stratégique aussi
bien pour la production énergétique que
pour notre patrimoine naturel en N
ensuite nous pensons que l'hydrolien
avec les forces Maré motrices est une
voie à développer au-delà de cette
production hydraulique historique le
soil et l'éolien sont à ce jour les
filières les plus avancées elles
présentent l'inconvénient majeur
contrairement au nucléaire et à
l'hydraulique d'être des énergies à
faible densité et surtout à caractère
très intermittent ce qui rend
obligatoire de disposer d'installation
thermiquees à flamme de puissance
équivalente il faut encore créer une
filière technologique localisée que ce
soit dans l'installation la maintenance
ou la fabrication des matériaux
nécessaires à ses productions
énergétiques il est donc essentiel
d'appuyer la création de véritabl
filières industrielles française dans
les dans les secteurs du photovoltaïque
et de l'éolien il nous paraît en effet
contradictoire et contreproductif de
défendre les énergie renouvelable et
d'importer avec un bilan carbone très
lourd des panneaux venus de Chine nous
devons donc développer la recherche dans
ces production énergétique et les
formations professionnelles pour que la
transition énergétique soit également
créatrice d'emploi et de savoir-faire
français cependant il serait illusoire
de faire croire que l'on peut
aujourd'hui se passer à court terme du
nucléaire de fission énergie à forte
densité la production d'un réacteur est
équivalente à celle de 2000 éolienne ou
à 100 millions de panneaux
photovoltaïques de 10 m² son coût du
kilowatt plus faible mais très
capitalistique est peu dépendant du coût
de la matière première et surtout les
exexant de production de CO2 en revanche
cette production énergétique présente
des risques incommensurables les déchets
et l'accident nucléaire or sur ce
dernier point la sécurité d'une
installation nucléaire repose en dernier
ressort sur les compétences
individuelles et collective des salariés
et sur leur esprit de responsabilité à
tous les niveaux d'où l'exigence de
salariés hautement qualifiés reconnu par
un salaire et un statut la
sous-traitance le recours au salariés
détachés en plus de faire courir des
risques en termees de sécurité impose
aux travailleurs des conditions de
travail inacceptables qui mettent leur
santé et leur vie en danger enfin la
détermination de la production
énergétique appelle un contrôle et une
participation démocratique dans le
domaine décisionnel comme celui de
l'expertise cela nécessite un potentiel
scientifique technique et industriel de
haut niveau il faut donc changer de cap
reprendre les reenes de la politique
énergétique et porter un projet au
niveau national comme au niveau européen
un projet politique et non comptable un
projet au service des peuples et non
démarché un projet qui seul permettra de
relever le défi immense d'une transition
énergétique réussie je vous remercie
merci Madame
cuckerman la parole est à Roland
Courteau
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues lors du dernier
congrès mondial de l'énergie en octobre
dernier un expert estimé que le monde
devra investir 30000 milliards d'euros
dans les les 20 années à venir pour
subvenir aux besoins en énergie d'une
population en croissance aussi bien
démographique qu'économique en France
laadem évalué à 105000 le nombre
d'emplois dans les énergies
renouvelables en 2010 contre 63000
seulement 4 ans
auparavant ce nombre a baissé à
99700 2011 principalement en raison de
la crise du secteur
photovoltaïque mais la même agence
estime que 825000 emplois pourrai être
créés d'ici 2050 grâce à la transition
énergétique c'est dire la fragilité de
cette croissance mais aussi les
perspectives considérables qu'offrent
les filières d'énergie renouvelable si
on sait conforter leurs fondamentaux la
France dispose d'atout des grandes
entreprises parmi les leaders de leurs
secteurs respectifs un territoire
relativement vaste par rapport aux
autres pays européens des ressources
naturelles importantes notamment
concernant la biomasse ou le secteur
prometteur des énergies marines le
gouvernement a bien compris l'importance
de l'approche filière c'est ainsi qu'à
la demande du ministre du redressement
productif et du ministre de l'écologie
et du développement durable et de
l'énergie un contrat de filière énergie
renouvelable a été présenté par Monsieur
Jean-Louis
lors du comité stratégique de filièr des
éco-industries qui s'est tenu le 9
octobre dernier il prévoit la création
de 125000 emplois supplémentaires d'ici
à 2020 et une balance commerciale
positive pour les équipements destinés à
la production des énergies renouvelables
le tissu d'entreprise de taille
intermédiaire devra bénéficier de
relation équitables avec les grands
groupes ainsi que d'une réelle
visibilité sur les orientations
politiques pour le développement du
système énergétique français il définit
enfin une politique de soutien à l'offre
afin de favoriser la compétitivité des
produits et services français à
l'exportation cela dit la coopération au
niveau européen comme l'a rappelé le
président de la République la semaine
dernière est toutefois essentielle dans
des secteurs où l'effort de recherche
mais aussi les économies d'échelle sur
les chaînes de production sont
déterminants jusqu'à présent on a eu
trop souvent l'impression que chaque
état mais aussi chaque entreprise
suivait sa propre stratégie or je crois
que les États dans un secteur
stratégique où les règles du marché ne
suffisent pas à elle seul à donner les
bons signaux doivent donner une
impulsion c'est tout par
particulièrement vrai en France où
l'État est actionnaire de plusieurs des
principales entreprises du secteur de
l'énergie qui font elles-même partie des
leaders mondiaux les tentatives de
coopération francoalemand sont resté il
faut bien le reconnaître très limité
dans le domaine du nucléaire mais les
énergies renouvelables sont un secteur
en pleine expansion sur lequel
l'ensemble des pays ont sinon des
stratégies commune a tout le moins une
volonté partagée d'avancer une alliance
peut donc être un jeu dont chacun
sortira gagnant
areva vient ainsi d'annoncer son
alliance avec la grande entreprise
espagnole Gama pour construire des
éoliens en mer dans le photovoltaïque
beaucoup disent que la cause est perdue
selon eux nous devrions simplement nous
adapter
à une division mondiale du travail les
Européens se limitant à installer des
panneaux
ù des modules seraient construit en Asie
cette analyse oublie qui reste des
progrès à réaliser concernant la
performance des panneaux comme
l'industrialisation de la production
ainsi le président du grand institut de
recherche allemand
franer a-t-il déclaré la semaine
dernière qu'il travaillait à la création
d'un consortium avec avec l'Institut
national de l'énergie solaire de chambie
et un institut suisse de son côté
Thomson Energie a annoncé le 20 janvier
le lancement d'une production de panneau
photovoltaïque en France avec 95 % de
composant
européens la baisse des coûts de
production en permettant d'ici quelques
années un développement sans subvention
du photovoltaïque rendra cette industrie
encore plus stratégique pour l'Europe il
sera essentiel alors que l'industrie
puisse prendre le relais de la recherche
pour produire la prochaine génération de
panneaux solaires c'est une question
d'emploi mais aussi d'indépendance
énergétique on a coutume d'opposer les
énergies renouvelables produites sur
notre sol aux hydrocarbures que nous
importons mais le gain en autonomie
n'est que partiel si les panneaux
proviennent en totalité d'un nombre
restreint de pays cela dit la production
d'énergie n'est que l'un des aspects sur
lesquels nous devons travailler une
filière énergétique doit envisager aussi
ce que l'on fait de l'énergie produite
jusqu'à son utilisation par un
consommateur domestique ou professionnel
c'est l'enjeu bien connu de
l'électricité solaire ou éolienne
produite de manière intermittente et
généralement pas au moment où on en a le
plus besoin il faut d'ailleurs préciser
que l'électricité nucléaire pas plus que
les énergies renouvelables ne peut
constituer une réponse unique aux
besoins des consommateurs difficile à
moduler rapidement l'électricité
nucléaire ne peut pas répondre à elle
toute seule aux pointes de consommation
qui affectent certains moments de la
journée la réponse idéale et le stockage
de cette électricité des stations de
transfert d'énergie par pompage step ont
permis de stocker une partie de
l'électricité pour l'aider à s'adapter à
la courbe de consommation leur modèle
économique semble difficile à trouver
pour les énergies renouvelables mais la
France dispose d'une expérience de 30
années en la matière a-t-on bien exploré
toutes les
possibilités c'est une bonne question je
crois du moins si l'impossibilité de
stocker l'électricité renouvelable
peut-être le point d'achoppement de la
transition énergétique une rupture
technologique dans ce domaine pourrait
au contraire enclencher une conversion
massive de notre système énergétique la
France a notamment un potentiel
scientifique et industriel de première
ordre pour mettre en place une filière
de l'hydrogène comme l'ont rappelé nos
collègues jean-Marc Pastor et Laurent
kalinovski lors de la présentation de le
rapport sur ce sujet devant l'office
Parlement en d'évaluation des choix
scientifiques et technologiques le grand
intérêt de l'hydrogène c'est sa
flexibilité il permet de stocker de
l'énergie mais il peut aussi être
injecté dans les réseaux de gaz ou être
utilisé par l'industrie pourquoi ne pas
mettre plus l'accent sur la
structuration d'une filière hydrogène
piste qui est suivie activement par des
pays tels que l'Allemagne le Japon ou la
Corée l'Allemagne expériment par exemple
la méthanation à ne pas confondre avec
la
méthanisation ce processus consiste à
transformer en méthane l'hydrogène qui
est produit grâce à l'électricité
d'origine renouvelable le potentiel est
considérable car on pourrait ainsi
utiliser à grande échelle les réseaux de
distribution de gaz pour écouler
l'électricité d'une certaine manière
produite de manière intermittente enfin
la production d'énergie ne doit pas être
un but en soi mais et un moyen de
remplir des services qui sont
l'éclairage le chauffage les transports
la question des filières doit donc
aborder aussi l'ensemble des services
aval qui permettent de consommer moins
et surtout de consommer mieux la France
dispose d'acteurs innovants et parfois
leaders dans des secteurs tels que
l'efficacité énergétique l'effacement de
consommation les systèmes de contrôle de
la consommation les réseaux intelligents
et les composants le photovoltaïque par
exemple ce n'est pas seulement des
modules de silicium c'est aussi des
onduleurs et une connectique pour
lesquels la France dispose de
spécialistes qui peuvent se positionner
à tous les niveaux de la chaîne de
valeur les filières ne se développeront
toutefois que si elles bénéficient d'un
encadrement adéquat deux points doivent
être abordés à ce sujet la
réglementation et l'accompagnement la
réglementation est une difficulté
rcurrente pour le développement des
énergies renouvelables non seulement le
cadre réglementaire est perçu comme
instable mais les annulations fréquentes
de textes réglementaires par le Conseil
d'État posent une véritable difficulté
aux professionnels qui ont besoin d'une
visibilité de long terme pour planifier
leurs investissements embaucher et
obtenir des financements auprès des
banques l'accompagnement doit donc faire
l'objet d'une attention particulière les
entreprises allemandes bénéficient de
condition de refinancement intéressante
auprès de la banque publique
KfW en France une institution telle que
BP France doit jouer le même rôle et
devenir la banque de la transition
énergétique l'accompagnement à l'export
sera déterminant l'industrie nucléaire
française ne doit pas être la seule à
bénéficier d'une forte image de marque à
l'étranger il faut parvenir à donner la
même visibilité aux acteurs des énergies
renouvelables la multiplicité des
acteurs qui n'ont pas toujours la
dimension suffisante justifie que les
pouvoirs public mènent une politique de
promotion active dans le cadre de la
diplomatie économique promue par le
ministre des Affaires étrangères mes
chers collègues le président de la
République a utilisé la métaphore de
l'Airbus de la transition énergétique je
souhaiterais à titre de conclusion
prendre cette formule dans son sens
littéral l'erbus lui-même devra faire sa
transition énergétique pour un jour
espérons-le voler avec un carburant
d'origine 100 % renouvelable la
transition énergétique ne consiste pas
seulement à construire des filières
industrielles nouvelles riches en emploi
pour nos territoirees ce qui est déjà
particulièrement appréciable mais aussi
à garantir la durabilité des filières
existantes en leur permettant de réussir
leur conversion aux énergies nouvelles
je vous remercie j'ai monsieur le
Président contteenu des observations de
Monsieur poatovski volontairement réduit
mon propos de quelques
minutes merci Monsieur Roland
courto la parole est à Monsieur Ladislas
ponatowski merci monsieur le
président
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je voudrais
d'abord remercier Jacques mzard le
président du groupe RDSE pour la
proposition qu'il a faite cont tenu de
mon intervention et je tiens à remercier
tout particulière Jean-Claude requier
mais avec qui nous sommes doublement
complices d'abord parce qu'on partage
globalement sur les problèmes
énergétiques la même position il se
trouve qu'en plus nous sommes tous les
deux vice-présidents de la fn CCR et que
nous séchons tous les deux ce matin le
conseil d'administration de la fnsr pour
être présent dans ce débat en toutous
les cas merci beaucoup à vous deux mes
chers
collègues si nous parlons souvent avec
raison de la problématique énergétique
nous l'abordons rarement sous le seul
angle de la production énergétique en
France les débats sur l'énergie se
perdent parfois sur les conséquences
écologiques de nos choix nous abordons
aussi ces questions d'énergie sous
l'angle de la sécurité des
approvisionnements nous l'abordons enfin
sous le prisme des économies d'énergie
malheureusement trop souvent nous nous
perdons dans un dédal de sophistiqu pour
ignorer cette unique
alternative limiter notre consommation
en énergie fossile car c'est seulement
en limitant notre consommation en
énergie fossile que nous réduirons notre
dépendance énergétique rétablirons notre
balance commerciale et contribuont à
diminuer les rejets de gaz à effet de
serre dans l'atmosphère je ne souhaite
pas anticiper autre mesure sur notre
proposition de résolution relative à la
transition énergétique que le groupe UMP
présentera le 26 février prochain mais
le basculement de notre consommation
d'énergie fossile vers la consommation
électrique doit être le fil rouge de
toutes les politiques publiques de
l'énergie que nous élaborerons dans
l'avenir en ce qui concerne la stricte
question de la production énergétique en
France problématique que nous abordons
aujourd'hui c'est tenter de répondre à
la question quel mix énergétique pour la
France en 1 heure 1h3 c'est vaste et
c'est peu d'abord un mot sur les
nouvelles filières de l'énergie que l'on
catalogue activement d'énergies
renouvelable ce qui n'est pas toujours
le cas ces énergies sont très
différentes les unes des autres
certaines sont renouvelables d'autres
pas certaines sont neutres en dioxyde de
carbone d'autres pas certaines sont
chères d'autres pas la question est donc
jusqu'où peut-on développer ces filières
énergétiques commençons si vous voulez
bien par l'hydroélectrique grand ou
petit ce mode de production n'est pas
nouveau il constitue même un des soctes
de notre production c'est une énergie
propre son coût est faible et l'énergie
est disponible en quelques heures seul
problème son potentiel de croissance est
très limité une étude menée par l'Union
française de l'électricité en 2011 a
réalisé un inventaire précis des sites
de production encore inexploités
elle révèle l'existence d'un potentiel
représentant environ 10,6 TWh soit une
augmentation potentielle de 16 % de la
production hydroélectrique annuelle
française ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
qu'il faudra compter sur les centrales
thermiques à combustiblees renouvelable
ou ce qu'on appelle la biomasse
c'est-à-dire le biogaz via les déchets
organiques au ménagés le bois énergie et
les
biocarburants ce type de production
n'est pas au sens strict du terme
renouvelable dans la mesure où le
combustible n'est pas illimité à
l'exception peut-être des déchets de
l'activité humaine en tout état de cause
le potentiel de ce type de production
électrique est largement
sous-exploité sa faisabilité technique
est avérée le combustible est peu cher
et quasiment illimité cette technologie
cependant a deux inconvénients d'abord
il ne faut pas que cette filière nuise
au développement des biocarburants qui
utilise eux aussi des matières
organiques issues du secteur agricole
enfin et surtout comme le monre très
bien les études de l'adè le biogaz est
émetteur de nombreux polluants comme le
biogaz oxyde d'azote le monoxyde de
carbone des composés organiques
volatiles des hydrocarbures imbrûlés et
des particules notamment des
hydrocarbures aromatiques
polycycliques pour mémoire mes chers
collègues la biomasse représente environ
1 % de notre électricité pour 6
tawh un mot sur la géothermie pour
l'instant une technologie largement
sous-exploitée nous savons qu'il existe
des CIT dans notre pays comme l'Alsace
où cette technologie peut se développer
également en région parisienne nous
faisons aujourd'hui encore des progrès
significatif pour conserver la chaleur
ici du sol qui est ensuite transformé en
électricité cependant cette technologie
connaît encore à court terme des limites
soit les forages sont peu profonds et
dans ce cas l'énergie se fait rare soit
les forages sont profonds dans ce cas
plus efficace mais ils sont aussi plus
coûteux il existe un risque sismique
les autres sources de production
électrique comme l'énergie marée motrice
sont marginales alors est bien sûr vous
l'avez évoquer les uns et les autres
l'éolien et le solaire C ces énergies
sont conséquen sont pardon sont sans
conséquences sur l'environnement mis à
part le caractère esthétique elles sont
renouvelables le seul problème de ce
type d'énergie c'est le coût nous sommes
quelques-uns à avoir travaillé sur une
commission d'enquête il y a peu de temps
et nous en savons quelque chose avec
l'éolien
la somme des coûts de production et
d'exploitation varie entre 6 et 12,5
centimes d'euros le kilwh pour le
photovoltaïque on se situe entre 12 et
25 centimes d'Euros je ne parle pas ici
du prix de vente dont on sait qu'il est
artificiellement gonflé malgré ces coûts
ces deux types d'énergie ont un avenir
certain surtout quand on voit que les
coûts de diminuent par exemple de 43 45
% entre janvier 2011 et janvier 2012 en
utilisant des modules monocr cristallin
et polycristallin pour l'éolien
l'équation est simple en moyenne une
éolienne française produit 1,55 MWh les
éoliennes produisent 1 MW supplémentaire
tous les 5 à 6 ans il y a donc des
potentiels énormes
mais l'équation n'est pas terminée la
production élienne représente un peu
moins de 3 % de notre production
électrique avec environ 4000 éolienes
pour atteindre 15 % de production issu
de l'éolien c'est 20000 éolien qu'il
faudra installer sur le territoire
national
simple règle de TR à comprendre 1000
éolienne par région c'est énorme et je
ne suis pas sûr que les Français soient
prêts à l'accepter même s'il tolère un
peu plus l'éoliens
offshore qu'est-ce qui reste le
nucléaire qui est incontournable une
énergie peu chère qui ne rejette pas de
gaz à effet de serre qui pose certes
deux difficultés le stockage des déchets
et son caractère non renouvelable
j'entends ceux qui nous disent qu'il ne
faudrait pas être a par le poids
économique du nucléaire en France par
les emplois qu'il maintient sur le
territoire par son effet sur la balance
commerciale par la vitrine technologique
que cette filière incarne pour la France
il se trompe tout cela est bon et même
très bon pour la France à court terme
mes chers collègues nous n'avons que le
nucléaire et les combustibles fossiles à
moyen terme et seulement à ce moment-là
le nombre de réacteurs pourra baisser
malheureusement puisqu'il fallait au
président de la République faire preuve
de son écolocompatibilité celui-ci a
annoncé la fermeture de la centrale de
fastenheim pour 2016 il fallait faire
une annonce prendre une vieille centrale
comme Bou émissaire et peut-être aussi
faire plaisir à un voisin mais aucun
élément ni dans les travaux de
l'Autorité de sûreté nucléaire ni dans
ceux de l'Institut de radio prototection
et de sûreté nucléaire ne donner raison
au président et à son premier ministre
ex en réalité ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que je mets à part le risque sismique
peut-être en région Alsace
sur lequel il y a débat même entre pro
et non pro vous l'avez compris mes chers
collègues l'UMP est très clairement
opposé à la fermeture de la centrale de
fon ce n'est pas une opposition de
principe nous pensons simplement que le
politique n'a pas à se substituer aux
experts et qu'il faut faire confiance
notamment à des organismes comme
l'autorité de surté
nucléaire quant à la quant au second
objectif monsie le président de la
République aller plus loin aller au-delà
c'est-à-dire jusqu'à diminuer la part du
nucléaire de 75 à 50 % d'ici 2030 l'UMP
y est totalement hostile c'est
techniquement
irréalisable c'est économiquement
totalement irréaliste et c'est surtout
insupportable pour les Français qui ne
sont absolument pas prêt à avoir leur
facture double d'électricité doublé mes
chers collègue en résumé nous
considérons que la France n'a pas les
moyens d'abandonner à court moyen ou
long terme les filières du
nucléaire ni d'ailleurs les nouvelles
filières de production d'énergie je vous
remercie merci Monsieur
patowski la parole est à Monsieur Renand
Dantec
bien monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues restant on est
plus extrêmement
nombreux néanmoins le groupe écologiste
se réjouit de chaque occasion donner de
débattre des questions énergétiques dans
cet
hémicycleb permet d'échanger un petit
peu on est d'accord alors déjà que j'ai
que 6 minutes
euh donc je crois qu'il est intéressant
effectivement la dis a dit qu'il y a des
objectifs aujourd'hui qui font l'objet
d'un contrat avec la nation qui étaient
les objectifs du président de la
République et que c'est dans ce cadre-là
que nous nous situons réduction par 4
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre en
2050 par rapport
1990 réduction de la part du nucléaire
de 75 à 50 % du mix électrique d'ici
2025 et c'est tout aussi important et le
président a été très clair là-dessus
lors de la conférence
environnementale réduction de la
consommation finale d'énergie de 50 % et
d'ici 2030 de la consommation de fossile
de 30 %. nous sommes bien donc dans une
logique de réduction de la consommation
énergétique française et les écologistes
soutiennent pleinement ces ces objectifs
constamment rappelés par le Président de
la République qui doivent donc sortir la
France de l'impasse du tout nucléaire
absurdité économique et environnementale
manifeste doiv permettre de réduire
notre empreinte carbone et élaborer
enfin une politique industrielle et
d'emploi innovante sur les questions
énergétiques cela nécessite cohérence et
réalisme le thème de ce matin était
notamment l'avenir de la filière
nucléaire notre parc actuel est
vieillissant les travaux nécessairire à
sa prolongation et sa mise aux normes de
sécurité post Fukushima vont coûter
extrê cher on le dit finalement assez
peu on évoque aujourd'hui une somme
entre 55 et 80 millions d'euros pour le
parc existant nous savons surtout un peu
plus que l'année dernière quand nous
étions dans cette commission d'enquête
avec le sénateur poniatovski que jamais
jamais le prix du mégateur d'origine pr
ne sera compétitif les plan financier de
la centrale d'incle point en
Grande-Bretagne le confirme le megaw il
sera a vendu pour plus de 40 ans de prix
garanti à plus de 100 € à comparer donc
alors là j'ai pas obligatoirement les
mêmes chiffres que la dislas au 80 € le
M le mgawh pour l'éolien terrestre ou 90
€ dans les dernières propositions pour
le photovoltaïque le Pr donc même en
filière mature ça devrait être le cas
pour les Anglais et donc plus cher et
alors concernant le prix du mgawh qui
sortira de flamand ville je crois qu'on
est dans le mégawatur électrique le plus
cher de l'histoire le chantier est passé
3 milliards à 8,5 milliards et il n'est
pas fini et c'est à peu près les mêmes
dérives de coût je le souligne en
Finlande le nucléaire a concentré et
concentre encore une écrasante majorité
du budget de la recherche française ce
qui nous av fait perdre beaucoup de
temps et prendre un retard économique
énorme sur le développement des filières
renouvelables avec donc des conséquences
négatives sur l'emploi c'est sur un
discours faux que s'est construit le
leur d'une électricité bon marché alors
que le mgaw est vendu sous son prix réel
comme l'avait clairement montré le
rapport sénatorial il est donc temps de
tourner la page de ce choix énergétique
qui affaiblit économiquement la France
et de réfléchir collectivement à une
sortie en bon ord en réorientant
massivement les investissements sur les
filières renouvelables dans le rapport
sénatorial nous avions notamment cité
les chiffres de la Fédération européenne
des producteurs d'électricité donc ce ne
sont pas des chiffres écolos qui montre
bien que le nucléaire se marginalise en
Europe même bien au-delà de l'exemple
allemand dans les 10 prochaines années
c'est 250 milliards d'euros
d'investissements qui sont prévus dans
les filières renouvelables alors que
c'est 16 milliards 15 fois moins pour le
nucléaire il est temps d'être présent
économiquement sur ces marchés je
reviens pas sur la question des gaz de
schiste je crois que la phrase de juin
2012 du PDG Dexon mob qui avait déclaré
sur les perspectives du gaz de chiste
dans le monde nous sommes en train d'y
laisser notre chemise est une bonne
conclusion de ce débat les Polonais
notamment sont en train de déchanter
plus que jamais les écologistes
appellent à une définir une politique
forte et cohérente pour le développement
des filières renouvelables le potentiel
industriel et de création d'emploi est
considérable là les précédents orateurs
sont allés dans le même sens et nous
attendons donc avec grande impatience
plus de précision sur l'annonce du
l'annonce du président de la République
d'un géant franco-allemand de la
transition énergétique sur le modèle de
ADS est-ce que c'est principalement sur
le photovoltaïque est-ce que c'est plus
large là nous cherchons encore une
partie de la réponse dans ce débat les
désaccords entre les uns et les autres
pas un débat en tout cas les désaccords
entre les uns et les autres sont sont
connus je souhaite juste donc dire un
mot de la filière hydrogène parce que là
malgré tout il y a peut-être quelques
convergences entre nous elles sont
précieuses puis qu'elles sont rares et
après le rapport de de l'OPEX remis à
Arnaud monbour cette semaine je crois
que nous serons assez en accord pour
dire l'immense
potentiel lié à à l'application power to
gaz la transformation effectivement de
l'électricité en hydrogène avec
possibilité de la remettre directement
dans le réseau les capacités de réseau
les chiffres divergent un peu entre
entre 5 et et 20 % mais là dans un
premier temps il y a déjà un potentiel à
développer il est temps de passer à des
expérimentations grandeur nature c'est
un élément de de stockage c'est un
élément de stabilisation du prix parce
qu'on ne parle pas assez du fait queune
des grandes difficultés aujourd'hui
c'est ces variations énorme sur le prix
de l'électricité avec des prix souvent
négatifs qui fragilisent l'ensemble des
filières mais nous savons donc tous que
il faut aller massivement aujourd'hui
sur le développement des renouvelables
nous savons aussi tous le rôle central
des économies d'énergie pour réussir la
transition énergétique avec derrière les
enjeux majeurs sur l'effacement sur
l'intelligence des réseaux sur les
mécanismes de capacité au niveau
européen et on voit bien que ceux qui ne
veulent pas de cette transition
s'attaquent aujourd'hui à ces
questions-là les mécanismes de capacité
les mécanismes défacement en les rendant
si possible peu performant pour conclure
mes chers collègues la Commission
européenne a présenté hier son projet de
paquet énergie climat pour 2030 il est
dcevant la France accueillera vous le
saverez en 2015 la conférence climat qui
doit arriver à un accord enfin à la
hauteur des enjeux sur les questions
climatiques la France doit donc se
mobiliser dans les prochaines semaines
dans les prochains jours pour relever le
niveau d'ambition pour les décisions du
Conseil européen de mars et pour cela
elle doit évidemment aussi apparaître
tout à fait exemplaire dans son propre
engagement sur sa transition énergétique
je vous
remercie merci Monsieur Dantec la parole
est à Monsieur Jean-Claude
Roquier bien vous donnez la parole à
Monsieur denud dans l'esprit de ce que
indiqué votre président tout à l'heure
d'accord je demande à Monsieur denud qui
respecte bien le temps sinon on dépasse
et tantôt il y a les questions
d'actualité donc je seraai forcé de
couper monur monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
permettez-moi en commençant de regretter
les conditions d'organisation de ce
débat et de déplorer toutes les
conséquences que cela pourrait induire
pour l'avenir d'avoir baclé un débat au
Sénat ceci étant je suis ravi que ce
débat ait pu avoir lieu mais il n'aura
pas lieu qu'on a inscrit cette question
à l'ordre du jour j'ai un texte écrit
que je donne au service je vais essayer
de vous
résumer est-ce que la France va
respecter les engagements qu'elle a pris
en matière de politique énergétique
serons-nous demain exemplaire comme nous
l'avons été dans le passé c'est tout
problème qui est posé nous avons pris
des engagements nous c'était en 2008
nous sommes à mi-chemin malheureusement
pas à mi-chemin dans la réalisation de
ses
engagements voilà vous avez donc pu
suivre ce débat sur sur la production
énergétique française et l'avenir de la
filière nucléaire on en reparle tout de
suite dans 24h Sénat présentée par
Delphine
Gérard